hey if you haven't already got it get
yourself a copy of answer the Internet
the card game it's available right now
in the link in the bio or you can get a
bar salal Mart Amazon or Spencer Gifts
play along with us that's gonna do it yo
let me understand - you know about to
answer the internet if you had to watch
your biggest enemy fought the girl of
your dreams in order for you to marry
her would you do it Dan
would I watch my biggest enemy [ __ ] the
girl of my dreams I mean it's how I met
my wife in the first place so I guess I
guess yeah entire Chicago Bears [ __ ] my
wife that's how I had to gauge how cool
she wasn't if she was doubt and she is a
Bears fan yes would you rather sit on a
cake and eat it sit on a cake and eat a
dick A or B sit on a dick any cake oh
wow sit on a cake and eat dick or sit on
a dick and he cakes you the problem the
first one is do I it does he had do I
have to talk to blow him till he's done
is if I could blow him to completion I
don't want to do that cuz that gives me
the creeps but I could sit on the dick
and eat some cake so I'll be thinking
about the cake man tiramisu if tiramisu
is considered cake and I'm good because
I will take a I will take an Italian
dick to me some tiramisu
would you rather give the firt would you
rather give the first 99% or the last 1%
of a [ __ ] I just covered this about
five seconds ago so you're going into
like you know several minutes I'll go
one for a couple of minutes I don't I
would rather I would rather I would
rather blow a dude I'd rather blow a
dude and not have him complete then just
take just the completion do you don't
have it yet because I can I've sucked on
my thumb when I was a kid I feel like a
thumb is a dick just you know put the
hole in it how about this would you
rather give a guy a good [ __ ] so it's
fast or a bad one so it lasts long I
knew I would give a good blow job I was
gonna blow into it I'd blow it
well I could blow it do it better than
half of the girls I think we need more
jobs over my life Poland talking smack I
guess you know it's not a wrench lady
would you rather be blind or [ __ ]
57% of Barstow readers choose being
blind of course you want to keep you
everybody wants to keep their dick
I would rather would you rather be blind
or [ __ ] I would take blind any day
of the week because you still feel your
dip you know maybe I mean the rest of
your life is miserably inconvenient
yeah but I know but I would still I
can't do anything by yourself no do but
I got a little bit of money I could
still get a girl to [ __ ] me okay would
you rather burp the sound of a gaunt
bone or sneeze the sound of a bowling
strike ooh this is kind of 55% of
Arsenal readers say they want the strike
most people say they would sneeze a
strike I know then I think burp the gong
is really fun I think Burke the gong is
fun because I hang out with a good
enough amount ageing us Bobby Lee's a
good friend of mine I would swell away
or just to burp the gong in front of you
successfully steal a base in the major
league we had 100 attempts
abso-fucking-lutely not and it didn't
say how many percentage of our field
people voted on this because everyone
would be a liar if they said they could
its embody that is almost impossible to
steal a base in a movie even if I had a
thousand attempts I still could do it
maybe when I was in high school and I
was on one going against high yeah but I
not even know I still could do it major
league would be you can I couldn't steal
base no never never not a million years
would you rather have a dog die every
time you laugh or have there be a
genocide every time you fall in love oh
man I the genocide is fine I've never
been in love it's not gonna be a problem
at all love is fake man I don't want to
kill dogs they're wonderful man actually
my dog's the only thing I have loved so
that's actually true sorry babe oh yeah
I would take the genocides fine well it
love comes once in a million years would
you rather have a three inch dick or
only last 30 seconds during sex well a
is already covered for me so
know when I'd rather have a three and
73% of Barstow readers said they'd
rather last 30 seconds during sex
instead of having a three inch dick
I guess yeah I guess you'd rather I
dressed yeah you'd rather just last 30
seconds to accept you could just keep
doing it you could just keep [ __ ]
over and over and over again and a three
inch dick music is not that bad how big
is three inches it's pretty small
like just over this card yeah I don't
nobody about this card one two three
this is about three inches
yes not that much yeah great oh you know
what I might just I think I would only I
think I would rather have I'd rather
have a three inch stick for the story
all the time nobody gets mad at small
tip guys a regular dick or a victim you
pull it out just two kids or one kid
who's handicapped and one kid that plays
in the NFL the NFL thing cuz you know
the NFL player would bring them on the
field one time they let him finish a
touchdown you know yeah they always let
him do that just one time you know what
you know what they always have like a
video that's condescending of like a
handicapped kid and a girl asks him to
prom
you know you've seen those videos and
just once I want to see the handicapped
kid say no you know me [ __ ] I'm
clipping on the side
would you rather would you rather be
able to have sex with any five people
for one year or get to powerbomb whoever
you want whenever you want for a year
wow that's cold would you rather be able
to have sex with five people for a year
and hit four yeah or get the power one
more power about wherever I want
whenever I want for an entire year would
be so fun you get to run up on someone
and just anywhere you want anyone you
want by the way without any sort of
penalty right yeah having sex with five
five people for years it's kind of like
that's achievable that's to some degree
would you rather have sex yeah you can
pick leave your five dream girls that's
you're never gonna get so much but you
never know you never know to powerwash
yeah and if I dream girls by the way
aren't they're not gonna be sure after
you do it once you're yourself
just like you did for everything ever
would you rather wake up every morning
with the TV channel numbers randomize
and no guide or have your have your
keyboard layouts which every morning oh
[ __ ] the TV for sure the key that would
kill me I barely can type radio' I'm so
shitty at that I still pack and type I'm
like a you are bad yeah I don't I don't
do it all the time but sometimes I if
I'm stressed out I need to like slow
down for a sec because I'm trying and I
miss a million words so I would rather
have the TV channels all scrambled and
[ __ ] I'm only watching like three
channels anyway I could find it but I
only watch three channels and I only
watch it because I still yeah you think
I'm not going to do you think I'm not
gonna find SportsCenter lifetime and The
Cooking Channel and I'm gonna figure it
out at some point would you rather have
50 grand straight to your bank account
or a half a million in pennies and you
can't convert it whoo Wow you can't
convert it so you just have to have the
penny that you have to pay in pennies
for the rest of your life yeah I mean
for the rest of the time that you get to
have money I guess you'd sit around roll
with them and I would go get a rolling
machine I'm gonna half a million I would
get a rolling machine but that's how we
would pay back people that I don't like
when I was how many money that gets on
my nerves I keep a man only in pennies
yeah cuz 50 grand stick to your bank
account you know that's not a sense
there's no fun there's one there's one
red rocky floors is jerking off to nudes
I'm a girl who has died weird or a nice
tribute oh I think the 51% of our soul
said it's weird
what man how is that weird I'm very
disappointed how was that weird fifty
one said it's weird so just over half
think that's a weird thing to jerk off
then you move on Dyess that off what I
mean I jerked off to people that at that
like the moment of points I die she
shoots number one on corn right right
that's that's the whole point you want
to see her history you see your catalog
well when I stopped watching movies at
people that diamond no but it's funny
scale see if it's like a person like a
porn star years old there because like
watching a movie of someone who died she
looks like this girl a girl that I knew
yeah depends on how she died murdered
horrible horrible murder might start
going on a little bit more
I don't know if it was someone I knew
that passed away but I don't really
choke off I don't jerk off to anybody I
know
so that's kind of see that's a hard I
don't I don't need jerk off to people
I've never met
I've never jerked off to someone I know
I've jerked off with people I know on
them or in them but I never get it I
never got to do it and jerked off let's
put it that way I never yeah new ones
are really just appetizers yeah yeah
this is popcorn shrimp you like oh man
I'm so excited for when this meal
commissary but this is good don't get me
wrong I like it I still want to stay
okay last one would you rather fight a
short would you rather fight a short
gladiator or a rhinoceros oh dude
gladiator anything rhinos [ __ ] [ __ ] up
they eat like 500 people a year in
Africa they [ __ ] have you ever seen
those videos we just through Kazan we
have their rabbit if someone here from
Zimbabwe and he just went home for three
weeks maybe old videos like that yeah I
just learned all about them and oh
they're murderers
well I mean I hear a meow so [ __ ] you
well I don't know man can you just if on
later dude yeah so if he's still tough
guy I mean I think you're still I think
you're losing both these fights here's
the problem here's the problem with the
glad or here's a problem to Rhino my
should say why that's a bad choice
because rhinos are always in packs too
you're gonna get [ __ ]
yeah I might win the one-on-one fight or
I might go down gloriously you're done
all right one of them's gonna pay you
down the other rounds and rip off your
limbs piece by piece
you watch your body get pulled apart oh
yeah I'd rather have the gladiator
because at least I had dignity when they
killed people right there was the whole
thing then clean kill I dread riches
right to the top right to my throne kill
me quick you know